euh on y était à cette couillon dis-moi
pas moi parce que j'ai autre chose à
euh j'adore en plus je suis à
fond derrière l'équipe de France et je
les adoré joueurs voilà je les kiffe de
fou j'en ai vu ce weekend j'en ai croisé
notamment j'avais j'ai envoyé un
reporter de guerre dans la Fan Zone
place de la Concorde on commence avec le
résumé de la soirée qu'on a vécu avec
des supporters français et nous allons
étaient très très heureux d'être là
regarde
et on commence cette soirée avec les
supporters néo-zélandais vous allez voir
ils étaient plutôt confiants au début
[Musique]
20h03 côté français on est tombé sur une
bande de jeunes qui était sobre et pas
du tout inquiet on va se faire en avant
après avec Henri Henri il est 20h03 on
va retrouver Henri tout à l'heure à 22h
Henri 20h03 un ami à 22h je ne te parle
plus enfin je moi je suis sur le match
les gars là bref aux alentours de 22h on
les a retrouvés c'était pas les mêmes
gars il est 22h30 on se sent comment
toujours aussi bien
alors j'ai l'impression qu'il y en a qui
est resté un petit peu à l'eau et on a
un autre voilà il a profité de la
mi-temps il est
on est resté sobre et c'est le plus
important et alors côté néo-zélandais
non plus c'était pas les mêmes gars
22h40 et c'est de la France c'est la
folie dans la Fan Zone et avec nos trois
copains
la France France
[Musique]
l'équipe de France a gagné son match et
on vous laisse avec un supporter
néo-zélandais très fair-play
moi je pense et les nations
[Applaudissements]
et c'est le seul endroit où on peut
trouver des gens qui n'y connaissent
rien au rugby et ça c'est magnifique
regardez ils n'y connaissent rien
et on commence avec le mec qui est très
content d'être là mais alors le rugby
c'est pas du tout sa tasse de thé
pourquoi tu es là
ce soir parce que j'habite à Paris et en
vérité j'aime cette ville tu aimes le
rugby pas forcément et on est tombé sur
une supportrice qui supporte des mecs
mais alors elle connaît pas du tout leur
nom de l'équipe de France
et après et je ne sais pas après et on
est tombé sur un mec lui sa technique
est simple donner des noms hasard
peut-être qu'il va tomber sur un vrai
nom de joueur ouais je me suis levé ce
matin je me suis dit pourquoi pas venir
je me suis jamais dit vas-y fais-toi un
petit tu t'appelles jean-médique ouais
je vais dire Anthony Anthony
Anthony Dupont Anthony Dupont bien sûr
et allez on continue j'invente des noms
de joueurs pour faire Georges mitonnet
partie 2 vous êtes pour les All Blacks
vous avez bien regardé les
couleurs mon favoris
et on termine avec le couple qui en a
rien à faire de l'Ovalie eux ils sont
juste venus là pour se pécho vous êtes
rencontré le weekend dernier et là c'est
le deuxième date en gros
et alors le premier bisou ça c'est fait
ou pas bah oui quand même
c'est pas beau l'amour
avec nous 21h03 on sait que vous aimez
nos débrises bon bravo la France c'est
un beau début de Coupe du Monde bien sûr
très bon début de France
cartonne oui tous les matchs ont fait 5
ou 6 millions hein même les matchs en
équipe de France qui est l'équipe de
France a fait 15 et ça a été un carton
on va pas se mentir avant même que le
match commence certains supporters a été
complètement fait mais vraiment bien
fait je me dis et puis la soirée avancée
et moins on comprenait ce qu'ils disent
le rugby c'est le moyen de se divertir
mais aussi de croiser des phénomènes et
on commence avec Yannick et son copain
ok fais genre c'est normal ok on est
tombé sur un phénomène qui a des tout
petits yeux encore plus petit que
Benjamin Castaldi on va gagner les gars
vous inquiétez pas pour ça
oh
attendez stop yannick a encore un
message pour nous ah allô l'OM désolé
mais allez l'OM vive la France et vive
la république et on est tombé sur le
papa de Guillaume Genton qui était en
pleine forme mais qui adore mettre des
vents
[Musique]
toujours avec Yannick qui a inventé un
nouveau métier MIM commentateur j'ai vu
aussi Antoine Dubeau qui l'a fait
voilà là on est d'accord et après j'ai
vu j'allais béret la fait comme ça squat
et on est tombé sur un nouveau métier
inconnu supporters
et on termine avec Yannick qui nous
offre un grand moment d'émotions
de la patrie le jour de gloire
et tu es arrivé
[Applaudissements]
c'est aussi le moyen de se faire un peu
d'oseille comment découvrir l'astuce des
deux pinces de la soirée regardez
qui dit Fan Zone di buvette qui dit
buvette dit consigne attention on est
tombé sur les rois des pinces regardez
les gars j'ai trouvé la plus grosse
pince de toute la place de la Concorde
ici on a la Fan Zone pour le match de
rugby 1 euro le verre c'est à dire qu'on
est à combien de rôles là là plus de 50
euros plus de 50 euros et vous allez
voir c'est pas fini les pinces sont de
sortie
[Musique]
parfait parfait vas-y à tout à l'heure
et une demi-heure après on les a
retrouvés vous allez voir c'est vraiment
des champions
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et alors bilan de cette soirée regardez
ils ont gagné plus d'oseille que moi on
a récolté plus de 75 euros ils ont payé
65 € par carte et 10 € par espèce je
suis pas un menteur on a plus de vert
et un truc qui a fait le buzz c'est la
tête de Kylian Mbappé lors d'un essai
français il était un peu tard sur la
célébration etc grave charrier sur les
réseaux c'était drôle
[Applaudissements]
je sais reconnaître un mec qui n'a
absolument rien capté qui essaie de
faire semblant bien tenté mais le temps
de réaction
c'était c'était assez marrant ça ça nous
rappelait cette vidéo on est on a on n'a
pas résisté on a voulu vous la mettre
cette vidéo de Jacques chiracle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors
vous l'avez on a été voir les supporters
et on va terminer enfin parler avec
Bernard dans un instant de l'équipe de
France aussi on m'a dit que des gens
avaient des messages à me faire passer
et à moins et aussi il y en a même un
pour Daniel Moreau
allez tout d'abord on est tombé sur
quelqu'un qui a confondu rugby et paddle
Cyril tu as intérêt à gagner le top 100
on est tombé sur pierre qui dans la vie
à deux passions le rugby et les
imitations pas ouf écoutez le petit
chéri ce soir on est là on veut que ce
match on va le gagner on le veut allez
les bleus allez les lions allez allez et
apparemment les étrangers adorent crier
votre nom et ça les fait beaucoup rire
[Musique]
et on est tombé sur Marc qui lui a une
façon très particulière pour faire la
bise je t'adore
c'est la grosse dark ici j'ai également
croisé Anthony un amoureux gourmand
faites très attention Cyril ma chérie je
t'aime chérie là pour demain
on est tombé sur favoto et Yanis
Marshall qui avait un petit message pour
vous Cyril
et puis il en faut pour tout le monde on
a aussi rencontré un fan de Daniel
Moreau on a un petit bon encouragement
pour les Bleus
enfin incroyable Cyril je vous ai croisé
vendredi soir dans la Fan Zone
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est magnifique